I've never seen it before.
So.
This.
Was pure care.
I'm jenny dell i lived at
nimbin for 11 years from 1974.
Having arrived there from england
and had i come to australia to see if there
was any form of counterculture here at
all. I didn't want to remain living in
england where i'd been brought up and.
Having arrived at perth and
and then travelled on to adelaide i
was sort of asking everywhere i went.
If there was any alternative culture.
Around australia and it turned out
that it was a year after the aquarius
festival had been held it never been
and the closer i got
to the eastern states.
The more people were saying oh you should
check out nimbin so i arrived here
actually on my way to the other turn table
land which i thought would be a nice
place to go and look at and i'd heard
that also alternative lifestyle
as living up there too.
And arrived in nimbin on a sunday
afternoon and went into the craft shop
and asked where's the commune and
everybody fell about laughing because
that was what everyone who arrived at
nimbin always used to ask was a commune
and the only commune at that time
was not strictly speaking a commune
but a co-operative that had been bought
immediately after the aquarius festival.
And it was about at that time. Twelve
hundred acres of land in a valley.
That had one. It's had a
sawmill at the end of it.
So there was quite a lot of tree
loss and erosion on the land already
but it had been sold by a
guy calls sam mackay to.
A co-operative of i think
it was 900 shareholders.
After the aquarius festival and
and set up as a sort of piece
of liberated land in a way
that was no longer on the open market but
that for $200 and a $50 joining fee.
One could become a shareholder and
and part of this extraordinary
experiment in land ownership
and. I arrived there with a caravan and.
A husband and two children and we lived
in the caravan for the first six months
or so that we were there
and then we're lucky enough to be able to
move into one of the very few existing
houses on the property.
I think there were probably four
or five old ramshackle houses
that had been pretty much
derelict when the land was bought
and we lived in one of those.
And we considered ourselves very lucky
to have such a large roof over our heads
because at that time it was very
tough a timetable falls. It was.
The early part of 1974 there
was the worst wet season
that people could remember for
years and years and years
and most people who moved onto the
land were living in temporary shelters
or caravans or tents
or whatever they could sort of scrape
together to keep the rain off them
and basically survival was the name of
the game. Nobody had very much money.
And so in a way we were very dependent
on each other for help and support
and transport because only
one family in maybe four.
I've or six would actually have
reliable transportation and at
that time time travel owned one big truck
which frequently used to be used to take
everyone to a dance or a party or to
the beach at the weekend or whatever.
Whence you came straight.
Well i had a very precise impression
of what it was i wanted the way
that i wanted to live
and sitting up in the north of england
through a very cold winter in
1973.
I looked at world atlas is to see on many
levels where would be the best place on
the planet for me to live
that would be possible for me to live
because of you know immigration allowances
and
that sort of stuff so first i was a track
to two definitely a warm climate i wanted
to be somewhere warm
and i first looked at what used to be called
british honduras which is now believes
in central america and that's a
very appealing and i looked into
that very carefully.
And but from those investigations it
looked as if you know to live the way
that i wanted to live would be quite
difficult there because of the sort of
political situation in
central and south america.
And at that time australia had a white
australia policy. It had conscription.
And it was involved in the vietnam war.
And all of that all of those
things were most unappealing to me
and particularly conscription
because i had a baby son
and so i sort of discounted a stray leo
though for an english person who wanted to
go and live in a warm climate it was
the obvious place to choose but then.
A lot of television
and radio coverage was given in england
to gough whitlam's campaign for election.
I guess that was 1970 through.
And i watched that
and was very interested in this guy he was
very favorably portrayed in the english
media and when he was elected
and announced an amnesty for draft dodgers
and the end of the white australia policy.
I thought that's it i'm going to australia
that that's the place i want to be
but in terms of counterculture i didn't
know what would what would be existing here
but i didn't know
that i wanted to live in an area well
away from major cities where it would be
possible to grow one's own food where i
even had a sort of pretty clear idea of the
kind of landscape
that i'd like to live in which was hills
with lots of fresh running water.
Not too far from the coast.
And
that i would want to be living in close
proximity to a large number of like minded
people but not necessarily in a commune
or household as such because i'd had some
experience of community living in england
and had found that for other
people more than for myself.
Young children in a commune
or household can be quite a problem because
parents have different ways of bringing
kids up and so on and it could lead
to to friction and difficulty.
So my vision was that i would have my
own little sort of unit with my kids
but be very close to and co-operative
with a large group of other people
and so it turned out that when
i arrived at nimbin exactly
that was starting to grow there
and it was so close to my
vision of how i wanted to live.
I couldn't have been closer it
was exactly the sort of ideas
that i'd had so i felt immediately
connected to the people here as
if you know this was like a. Long
lost family or something and.
And very quickly settled
into the living here
and in those days really none of us
had anything you know we were all
very poor we had no money we had no jobs.
We were pretty dependent on government
benefits in the early days as well which.
Is you know an aspect of of nimbin life
that i have had many
differing positions on and
and the one i feel now is quite different
from the one i had then i guess
but in the early days we looked on the
dole as a form of rural subsidy where it
allowed people like ourselves to
establish ourselves on degraded land
and there's no doubt
that the land was terribly
degraded by years of over grazing
and being used as pasture in
the dairying cattle industry
and also from being over logged
and eroded because of that so.
We felt that we you know were there to
put something back into the land and.
And also take the land off the endless
cycle of capitalism and property.
As inland being being a
sort of form of currency
that by the very act of purchasing
it cooperatively and having rules
that said it could never be sold without
everyone's agreement we we actually to the
land out of that situation which was.
You know ideologically an
agreement that we all had
and one of the very few things
that we all agreed on. And.
I think because we were so poor that we had
to depend on each other and we had to.
We had to live very closely together
and share an awful lot of things
that suburban families and.
People you know who live sort of ordinary
lives in the outside world don't share
and that's a very taxing
thing to do and you.
It doesn't always not
always a smooth path and.
I think looking back on those early years
of tundra book falls in the mid to late
seventies the stuff
that we learnt about living with other
people about human nature about ourselves
about tolerance and
compassion and. Sort of.
Looking at something from
other people's points of view
and from many points of view.
Was it was beyond price.
I can't imagine a better training
than than that and it seems now
that the children who were babies
then and are now in their late teens
and early twenties have
grown up steeped in
that culture
and have emerged into the
world incredibly enriched
and i you know any comparison is odious
but i really think that that the kids
that grew up there during
that time and surrounded by
that kind of activity have have something
extra. You know that other kids.
Unfortunately you know don't have
unless they've lived in in very special
circumstances as well with things.
Well i think i think that was one of
the reasons why it did work the fact
that it was very hard to make rules and
and have everybody agreeing
on the same issues.
I think was one of the reasons why it
was possible for everyone to stay there
because i think if there had been a
very rigid structure then it wouldn't.
We were too individualistic and it
wouldn't have worked and people people.
Would have fought too hard
but interestingly although i've just sort
of eulogized how wonderful the effect of
it was on the kids that there was
things about kids there that for me.
Didn't work
and in fact constituted the reason why
i left tangible falls after two years.
And that was that.
It was very laissez faire
and anything goes with kids
and i was a parent who although i
was choosing the counterculture
and i was choosing you know to reduce
everywhere i could see the forms of all
sorrow to you and dominants that i
was wanting to expel from my life.
At the same time i i felt that to
bring children up with no boundaries
and no limits was quite
a confusing thing to do
and it was putting too much responsibility
on tiny children to constantly be giving
them choices about what time they went to
bed or you know how far they could roam
or whether they got
home before dark or not
and i'm talking about you know children
from 18 months now up to say six years old
because there weren't many at that time
who were older than six maybe one or two
but not many and my children were very
small and the children ran in a pack
and that was terrific and it was you
know there were many advantages in that
but there were also disadvantages in
that i felt some other parents weren't
quite as keen to take responsibility for
their kids whereabouts and
activities as i was and i.
I was in a very much a minority and
wanting to set limits are my kids
and in the end.
It happened that darkness fell
and bonnie was an 18 months old had
been out with the kids all day
and i didn't know where she was it had
been raining the creek. It was up.
It was a worrying time and what a wonderful
when it's dark it's dark. No lighting.
There's no streetlights raining.
And i went across the creek to the family
whose children she i knew she was with
and they were all stoned.
And i said you know.
He hasn't come home and i'm really worried
and they all laughed and said it's cool.
And i thought you know i've
had enough of this idea.
I don't want to live like this.
This is scary and she
got home and she was ok
but all the same i began to feel
that you know i really needed to get
the kids away from a situation like
that now that was a decision i had to
make for my own peace of mind and it
and it doesn't mean to say
that children who remained in
that situation haven't emerged just as
wonderful and you know terrific kids.
As could be but for me it was a bit
too uncomfortable to do so for me.
That was one thing
that didn't work out.
Well it was a natural part of life. You
know it was it was a part of life.
It was part of everybody's life i can't
think of anyone who had no experience no
there wouldn't have been anyone who had no
experience of being smoked around them.
And there wouldn't have been many people
who wouldn't you know have a toke of the
joint as it went by. But at
that time also very
importantly in that context.
There was only one
person that i knew of at
that time who lived untouchable fools
who went to the pub who drank at all.
I mean occasionally people would have a
drink and the guys would have a beer
or something like that
but there's only one person who i would
have identified who had a drinking problem.
You know drank all the time and got
drunk and abusive and horrible and.
And it was nobody nobody thought of going.
The pub it was it wasn't part of
our culture to go to the pub..
As time went by that changed
quite dramatically in fact.
But on occasions where i remember
when there was a big police
busted underwear 1978.
And everyone was taken into lismore
and kept in custody all day
and then they were let out in the evening
and then they all went to the pub
and they all got drunk and they they
came back in the tundra the red truck
and you could hear the truck when
it hit the top of the valley and
that from where i live. That
was about two miles away
and you could hear them singing in the
truck as they came down the valley
and they were incredibly drunk and i'd
never seen that before it was the only
and all since actually i've never seen a
whole lot of tangible people incredibly
drunk all in a big pack
it was very unusual.
The drug bust was it was a
debacles from beginning to end
but at the time it was very frightening.
At
that time i suppose there would have been
about him about 200 people living it tangible
in various dwellings some houses in course
of construction some existing houses
and tents and so on.
And it was a simultaneous raid on several
parts of the community because we had
established little hamlets which were
like tiny villages in the valley
that were clustered around central
facilities like you know washing up
and shower and toilet facilities and.
The police arrived before dawn.
It was a commando style raid they
were in there were some uniformed
and some plainclothes police there i've
been sort of army trucks like covered
trucks and and sort of the ones
that came down to near where i lived at the
north end park to a short distance from
where. So i was living
and right next to the house of the
guy who'd originally owned the land
and still had an agreement
after he'd sold it
that he could live there until his death.
And the first person to
become aware before dawn
that they were there was his housekeeper
who was a middle aged nimbin
circulate she was
that you know an original person of the
area who never had anything to do with
marijuana
and who has life had been quite changed
by the advent of 200 hippies into her
backyard. But she was a most loving
and compassionate and tolerant woman
and very friendly with
all of us and very kind.
And it was her birthday
and she woke up to to see this shadow
of a truck coming under the trees
and then these figures in uniforms
with guns jumping out of the truck
and she was absolutely terrified.
As well we all as these guys you
know approached various to wellings
and you know came in and turned everything
upside down looking for marijuana.
Which you know when you think back on
it was very foolish it was august.
You know
and i mean anyone who knows anything about
the marijuana growing season would not
come looking for anything in august.
Anyway they came
and of course they found little
stashes of dope little ends of joints
and stuff in practically every
house they visited naturally and.
And they took people from just
about every household into lismore
and fingerprinted and photographed and
charged them with possession and.
I wasn't among the people arrested
but there were people in my
household who were taken in
and i mean the whole thing
was terribly frightening
and there was so many young
children at wonderful at that time
and for one of their early childhood
experiences to be commando style raid on their
home and the removal
of significant adults.
Their life from their environment people
who died experienced as being harmless
humorous gentle people to be so
violently removed from their
homes was was a really a
shocking thing to happen.
And you know i mean none of us were
living there in order to subject our kids
and ourselves to that kind
of shocking violence.
But it happened and eventually
there as due process was observed
and everyone had to appear in court and.
The scene at the lismore
court house on the day
when the charges were to be
answered was extraordinary.
We had musicians and dancers and people
looking beautiful and soaks and satins
and a festival atmosphere
outside the courthouse and
and some pretty smart lawyers from
sydney as well and a barrister and.
It was discovered quite early in the piece
that the original warranted
actually been invalid.
And the police ended up
with egg on their faces
and all the charges had to be
dropped and nothing came of it but.
What remained was the fact
that we had been violated
that the community had been violated.
Sure it may be that you know if we had
been breaking the law in a big way
or been anyone living there who at
that time was making enormous amounts
of money out of growing marijuana
that there might have been a little
more excuse for it than there was
but then i suppose it's a sort of tax you
pay on turning your back on on some of
the rules of the society and deciding
that you can set up under
a different set of rules.
And we certainly paid
that tax subsequent years
there were people in
that area who were growing a lot
of marijuana for profit. And.
That's never felt very good to me either.
And you know i as that
started to happen i'm.
I began to feel that i wasn't really
interested in that either you know.
And of course a lot of us now who were
you know into the dope culture then
i'm not in it. Now maybe we've grown
out of it or you know whatever
but it did become i think a
little overrepresented it niman
and certainly overrepresented
there now and it's a problem
that that's become a problem
where in the very early years.
It was actually part of a solution.
It wasn't a problem at all and
in fact a lot of people or not.
A lot of people but you know a good dozen
or so people came to nimbin in order to get
away from the cities who had been drug
addicted in the past to hard
drugs like heroin specifically
and they can turn in been in order
to be away from that culture
and successfully stayed away from it
because there wasn't any heroin at nimbin
and the little marijuana that people grew
and sort of shared among themselves was
was used in much the same way as people
have a drinks cabinet in other households
and it was a form of relaxation
and you know some people used
it as a creative stimulant
or whatever and they didn't
seem to be such a problem
but over the years a lot of people
became very dependent on it
and you know i don't believe you can really
be addicted to marijuana unless you're
an addictive personality and you know
that wasn't marijuana it
would be something else
but certainly some of the behaviors.
Later on when when there were people who
become habituated over many years to.
Using large quantities of marijuana
that began to look at you know a bit
weird because it does tend to sap you of
motivation and energy and perhaps more
might have been achieved without it.
Where can i really don't know
but i would say that it certainly
wasn't until the eighties
and i don't know how
far into the eighties.
It's quite an extraordinary
thing for me personally
that you know despite having been part
of the counterculture for so long
and having known hips of junkies
and you know people who've who've been using
i've never actually seen heroin in my
whole life
and so i really i only became conscious
of it i suppose about 80 to 83
that there were people who were using
or at least tasting you know
not actually regular users.
I think it was around that
time that i became aware
that one of the daughter of some people
that i sort of didn't know awfully well
but i knew quite well
and they had a daughter
that time would have been about 17 16
maybe and that she was using and that and
that seemed to me really shocking
and i hadn't really been away at
but then i became aware that there were
other adults who who had been using and
that they were sharing it.
Yes it was
and my kids who are coming
to be close to teenage
and that was very scary
that there was a teenager in town
who you know who'd been offered
and it accepted the use of heroin.
Was quite alarming to me and.
Yeah i didn't feel like it was a good
place to stay once a kids came to
be that. Age. Also because by
that time i was living in the main street
of town which is a very very different
situation from living out in the hills as
most people did i don't think they may
have been two or three other
people living in town.
You know who were part of the sort of new
settler movement and the main street.
It's sort of where it all happens
and it's often said of nimbin
i think it's true that.
It probably doesn't have any
more problems than other places
but at nimbin they're really up front.
They're on the street you can see them
they're not hidden away in alleys
and pushed out of sight under
the carpet sort of thing.
Doing that.
You know i think
that is one of what in a way it's a problem
in another way it's it's one of the
great blessings of nimbin that they're
that it's such a tolerant community
and so tolerant of deviance
but there's a sense in which that was okay
when we were in a you know early twenties
and we were as a group of people we
tended to throw the baby out with the
bathwater. You know we'd
thrown out all the.
Customs and belief systems and values
that our parents had
sort of instilled in us
and were gradually re assimilating
what seemed to be important to us
and holding onto a certain
perhaps a new set of values
that we created for ourselves we were
certainly creating a whole new culture.
And so in
that sense we were very open to new
definitions of what was right and wrong.
What was ok and not ok and that was fine
but i think as we've grown now and we're
now in our 30s 40s and fifa. Did.
Most of us who were there
then you know forties now.
I think we've needed to to set a few more
limits than we've been prepared to set
and that is time for that now and
we haven't done quite enough of it.
From myself.
Well i hope we've grown wiser and
we've certainly grown older and
that doesn't mean to say
that there isn't an extraordinary youthfulness
about as well you know for being in
our forties and fifties we're still
ready at the drop of a hat for a rage
and dance and you know i mean we're very
energetic people for you know despite.
Almost unbelievable age
and i think there's something
about having spent those years
that mean that's kept us
mentally very youthful
and spiritually youthful.
Go back to a time.
Role.
Yeah. The roles of men
and women on tangible in particularly
in the earlier years were not
that dissimilar from out in the
rest of society in the sense
that the women tended to
get the household duties
and the men tended to be out there
doing whatever they did out there
and in the case of tangible that was
largely a matter of clearing a site
and building a house.
And it wasn't so much divided along
sexist lines per say as it was down to
whose physical energy was most
appropriate to the task and given
that most of the women who were there
and there weren't many women there.
There were nearly all men
and women who were there were generally
either in relationship with a guy
or was single parent so babies
were involved in nearly every case
and
that being the case it was more sensible
for the guy to be the one who was clearing
the site and building the house
and for the woman to be the one who
was washing the nappies in a bucket.
You know with no washing
machine or anything like that
and keeping an eye on the kids and
that's not to say that that was rigid
but it was generally how it fell.
And we used to have a women's group
that met in nimbin once a week and
that was the one night of the week
when the guys got the kids no
matter how they felt about it
and there was you know quite a
lot of uproar about that too.
And city feminists who visited our
meeting were absolutely appalled
that we you know first of all had to fight
with our guys to get them to look after
the kids one night a week so we go
to a meeting but also the rest of it
that you know that that in their
view it was it was divided.
So rigidly along sexist
lines of occupation
but from our point of view you know me
more than anything we come here for peace
and harmony and happiness and that seemed
to be the way that we were you know
that things would be most
peaceful and harmonious.